right we'll stick that back well I mean
don't get me wrong some girls do learn
and make better decisions but the
problem is we're just thinking about us
because why does a man have to deal with
that but in the same why does he have to
deal with a girl that can't learn young
like why why wouldn't he just marry a 22
year old because she's yeah that's
that's what also what's crazy about that
though you're saying that but then men
also prefer young women that haven't
learned that um
no that's how what so exactly young
women yeah
they haven't learned they haven't been
through these they haven't learned no
boom they haven't been through these
problems that that create more problems
for me in the future so whether or not
you've learned okay I can I can help to
teach you the right way to do things I
don't want to have to teach you the
right way after Batman have run through
you and then it becomes more of a hassle
for me to try and develop this
relationship because you have their
problems Junior